first to help us make hard-earned
american cash uh a man who uh just
called the stanley cup finals from the
bubble in edmonton
and tomorrow returns to handicap horse
racing on the preakness stakes that's
saturday at 4 30 p.m eastern time on
in bc the final jewel of the triple
crown it's so
it's wild it goes belmont kentucky derby
and now
uh on october 3rd crazy um
preakness takes none other than eddie
ulcek how are you doing eddie
i'm doing well rich thanks for having me
and hopefully the uh hopefully the rams
over the giants on sunday is one of your
uh
one of your plays on sunday i'm not sure
if it is okay
i'll just i'll just throw that one out
there okay i'll
i'll i'll bite uh what do you where did
that one come from eddie what do you
like just
just just talking look at we're we're
we're talking about making a little
extra money and
uh we got horses tomorrow we got
baseball today we got
you know we got everything going on so
we got our uh we have a plethora of
opportunities uh
in all walks so we got the equine
athletes tomorrow at
pimlico for the preakness as you
mentioned and then we got the national
football league on sunday so
hopefully we'll be able to nice little
daily double maybe give the winner of
the preakness and then
if people want to get their feet wet on
the rams then we'll try to help them out
outstanding use of plethora eddie i
appreciate that before we get to
uh before we get to uh the preakness uh
i'll give you the floor on the tampa bay
lightning and their
and their championship hoisting the cup
in the bubble in edmonton and bringing
it to
uh to a spot where you know maybe the
rays or
bucks might be able to add to
to the to the run here what what did you
make of that uh that championship
yeah pretty amazing if you are a sports
fan uh down in tampa
considering what the lightning we're
able to pull off rich and
you know we talked last year about uh
you know the the misstep that they had
last year where everybody thought
that they would win the stanley cup and
you know they were the best team in the
league and they got swept in four games
and
you know all hell broke loose but they
really changed the dynamic of their team
i think they understood what they needed
to add and they need to add some some
grit they needed to add some toughness
they had it to
get some experience you know they were
able to do all that and
look at they had to go play the team in
around one of these playoffs
that took them out last year and
everybody thought that columbus was
going to be able to do that
and they won in five games you know they
took out boston in five games
and then they worked themselves to
edmonton and went six games with the
islanders so the road was not easy
they were challenged they answered the
bell and they were a little healthier
than dallas that look at tip of the
hockey home with the dallas stars i mean
they
made a hell of a run and unfortunately
for them and it happens in all sports
uh doesn't matter but especially the
most crucial time
uh injuries play a part of it and for
dallas they were
trying to play five-card stud with three
and a half cards and they just came up a
little
a little short on that aspect but tampa
deserved it and john cooper the head
coach did a hell of a job so
it was fun to be a part of and just an
amazing job by the commissioner mr
bettman bill daley the deputy
commissioner and everybody involved to
be able to pull it off and a lot of
people didn't think it could happen and
i think it's great for the game and
hopefully we'll have hockey sooner than
later and
hopefully we can all get on the right
side of this uh this pandemic and get
back to whatever the
the new normal is going to be for all of
us yeah and i want to bang the stick on
the ice also too for our colleagues at
nbc sports and sam flood and everybody
else that's been putting these games on
including you and that bubble and
and you know the the nhl was as i
mentioned earlier
you know the last ones yeah to announce
you know they were one of the first to
announce who's in but they were one of
the last to announce the where and the
when
and they're the first ones in north
american sports to complete a season and
hand out
right the trophy and that's just got to
be that's a great point
again excuse me for interrupting that's
a great point i i didn't want to
not jump in there and then because i
would forget that i wanted to make this
point you're right i mean
the commissioner the leadership that he
had of
being out front when there was something
to be said he was there when there
wasn't he went underground and stayed
low and just
had a plan right and you're right they
came back they were the first to
announce it but they waited they waited
they waited because
they had to they had to be able to be
flexible when it came to the virus
like they wanted you know look there's
no doubt they wanted to have one of the
bubbles in the states there's there's no
question they wanted to have one of the
bubbles in the u.s
but it just wasn't the right thing to do
so they waited
they were able to go to canada do the
deal with the government there get
everybody involved go to toronto go to
edmonton
and to be able to pull this thing off
you're right and i'm glad you mentioned
you know uh sam our boss amplet our boss
at nbc
and and uh you know just the leadership
and all the men and women that
sacrificed a lot and again we we
understand what's going on in the real
world we had a job to do and
we were there to try to entertain not
only the people so called in front of
the camera but
people behind the scenes to be able to
make it work and uh
it was just like it was it was hard uh
but it beats the alternative it was a
great experience and hopefully it's uh
you know people enjoyed the uh enjoyed
the broadcast and were entertained at
least for a couple of hours
each and every night or on some of the
days rich when we had five
i know right you had hockey from noon
eastern until
two in the morning so it was it was a
lot of fun and something
it's just an amazing feat it really was
they're just amazing how it was pulled
off on on every aspect of it eddie i'll
check here on the rich eisen show let's
get to it now eddie
all right let's make some hard-earned
american dollars for people or canadian
depending on where you're you're betting
uh what do you see in the final jewel
again of the triple crown preakness
stakes saturday 4 30 eastern
from pimlico uh in maryland what do you
got for me um
i am i am all in i am all in on art
collector the three horse
tomorrow in race 11 at pimlico he was my
derby horse but unfortunately for art
collector he got a little banged up he
was
unfit so unfit to perform in the
kentucky derby i'll use a phrase from
the national hockey league while being
in the bubbles he had a minor foot
problem he's been training like a
monster
since the foot injury he is a perfect
four for four rich this year
uh and since going a route of ground
this race is a mile and three sixteenths
a preakness
this horse going two turns on the dirt
has just become an absolute monster now
all due respect to
the team of johnny velasquez and bob
baffert who won the kentucky derby with
authentic
uh i think our collector is the horse to
beat i think you get every bit of uh two
to one to five to two meaning if you bet
two you win five so you put seven in
your pocket
uh i like that uh i like how that sounds
so i'm gonna be all in on the three
horse art collector there is some
i think there's some fast pace in this
race and i'm hoping that our collector
can be sitting maybe fourth or fifth
as they make the first turn and uh and
be able to mow them down down the lane
so i'm going to be all in on the three
horse art collector to win the
uh to win the preakness tomorrow which
sounds uh great and it sounds reasonable
but let's go unreasonable who wants to
win seven bucks man uh so what else what
else we got
what else are we doing rich like i know
how you roll and i've talked to some
people that you know
what are we gonna if you if you just add
a few zeros to that if you bet 2 000
no no no it's called moderation
eddie eddie there's something called
moderation
come on let's uh let's just bump it just
to kick it up a notch we'll see
who else you're playing with the three
horse use authentic you have to use the
favorite there's no doubt so i think if
it comes in three nine i think if you
make a two dollar exacta you know it's
gotta come in an exact order of three
nine
i think a two dollar investment will
turn into maybe maybe like eleven
dollars or so sorry about twenty you
went 110.
about 200 you get back 1100 okay so
that's not a that's not bad day's work
there for a minute and 58 seconds and
also my long shot for the race tomorrow
will be the 11th horse
uh live your beast life no no on the
outside with trevor mccarthy probably
get every bit of uh 25 to 1 and hoping
the 11
can hit the board so 3 9 11 for yours
truly
in the preakness tomorrow uh from
baltimore all right our collector
authentic live your beast life which is
no there's no
there's no spaces it's just one long big
ass name
um all right so then that's the way
you're rolling
okay three nine eleven that's it so so
the plane was art collector onto the
rams
on sunday okay is that called a parlay
is that what that is i don't know i'm
again i'm an nfl employee and a half
absolutely thanks eddie you take care of
yourself let's chat again soon
it's etio right here